esa Estefani frapac se convertirá el
jueves en la primera mujer que pite como
jueza principal en un mundial de fútbol
masculino será en el Duelo entre Costa
Rica y Alemania y además la van a
asistir otras dos mujeres en las líneas
hablamos de la brasileña neuquén y la
mexicana Karen Díaz Medina solo el
cuarto hombre el árbitro el cuarto
árbitro el salvadoreño said Martínez va
a ser un hombre ya había sido frapar la
cuarta árbitro en otros dos partidos
ahora le toca llevar el silbato volvemos
con Natalia acatar para preguntarle Qué
sabemos de Stephanie frapartd Y cómo
llega a esta posición histórica para el
fútbol femenino o para las mujeres
dentro del fútbol
es Sencillamente la mujer que todo el
mundo conoce como la señora árbitro no
solamente en Europa no solamente en
Francia sino también en Europa Tiene 38
años y ella fue la primera mujer en
arbitrar un partido en la segunda
división francesa eso fue en 2014 ya
cinco años después llegó a la famosa
liga Ay desde entonces pues ha tenido
una carrera supremamente fulgurante
pitando ya encuentros de la Liga de
Campeones y más recientemente en el
verano de este año en la final de la
Copa de Francia así que pues ha sido
muchísimos años de una carrera en la que
ella pues sea siempre mostrado muy muy
pertinente en todos en todo su juicio a
lo largo de todos estos partidos y es lo
que finalmente pues pareciera la edad la
oportunidad finalmente de de poder
arbitrar este partido en lo próximo
jueves ella forma parte de esa lista
bueno de 36 árbitros que se escogieron
para este mundial y hay otras dos
mujeres que están es decir son solamente
tres mujeres como árbitros digamos ya de
campo además de ella estaría muy cansawa
y también yoshimi y amazida que es de
Japón Así que vamos a ver porque como
usted bien lo decía pues en estos
últimos en todos estos partidos siempre
las veíamos como cuarto árbitro y todos
nos decíamos en qué momento es que una
mujer va finalmente a pitar y Bueno pues
hoy ya se dio a conocer esta noticia y
será entonces la francesa Stephanie
fatal a la historia este año ha sido sin
duda digamos el año del fútbol femenino
con
llenos asistencias enormes que hemos
visto en en partidos tanto de la Euro
como de la UEFA Champions League
femenina para al mismo tiempo también un
mundial un año de tareas pendientes
recientemente Vimos una protesta de
jugadores de fútbol sala que reclamaban
que se instaurará también un mundial
femenino Hasta qué punto esta medida es
reflejo de esa Progreso del papel de la
mujer en el fútbol o por otro lado
podría ser respuesta a todas las
críticas que se han recibido a la
organización acatar y a la FIFA por el
tema del papel de la mujer en el mundo
árabe
Pues yo diría que tal vez las 12 Omar Es
cierto que hubo toda esta protesta de
las de las jugadoras de fútbol sala que
justamente en el pasado mes de en este
mes de noviembre para comienzos de este
mes pues salieron a denunciar la falta
de igualdad la falta de de promesas
cumplidas por parte de la FIFA que lleva
desde hace más desde cinco o seis años
diciéndoles que en algún momento va a
crear finalmente esa Copa Mundial de
fútbol sala que ya existe en la
categoría pues sea masculina incluso
desde los años 80 y finalmente pues ya
digamos que ha llegado Esa esa gota que
hizo desbordar la copa y ya las mujeres
pues toman mucha más fuerza para
precisamente reivindicar esto lo hemos
visto también con el crecimiento como
usted lo decía el desarrollo del fútbol
femenino de la mundial que se vivió de
hecho en Francia en hace hace cuatro
años y pues Finalmente sí ha venido
creciendo Y pueden ser esta
reivindicaciones pero también aquí en
acatar pues lo que vemos es y lo digo ya
digamos de lo que se puede ver aquí
también en cuanto a medios o muy pocas
mujeres las que cubrimos este mundial de
fútbol muy pocas mujeres también de
fotógrafas pocas mujeres a camarógrafos
Así que tal vez Esto es algo que debe ir
creciendo poco a poco de ambos lados y
también algo que debería cambiar en la
dirigencia y es más difícil porque es
sobre todo los hombres los que dirigen
el fútbol en el mundo que sea la FIFA
que sea la UEFA o incluso en la
Suramérica Pues en la conmebol y sabemos
que finalmente Pues el fútbol femenino
ha venido ganando él lo vimos de hecho
además con este mundial último que hubo
de la Sub 17 cuando Colombia llegó a esa
final vimos también toda la polémica que
generó las declaraciones del presidente
de la federación colombiana de fútbol
sobre las jugadoras que no las
consideraba profesionales así que todo
esto Pues debe ir sumando puntos para
que haya un mayor acceso para para las
mujeres pero sí a veces hay que esperar
que estos gestos no sean gestos un poco
para acallar voces sino en realidad para
que sí haya un cambio de posición y de
mayor igualdad hacia las mujeres en el
deporte y en el fútbol precisamente
Natalia Muchísimas gracias por